aujourd'hui l'inventeur génial le visage
d'erik un belge de 15 ans déjà inventeur
du flotteur pour savons mais qui recevra
cette année l'oscar pour tout autre
chose
c'est tout ça est une fourchette à
refroidir les aliments alors on allait
voir ici un tuyau et quand la police eut
l'airpass est refroidi aliments comment
tu l'a construite
j'ai pris une fourchette que j'ai fauché
à la mère d'un copain j'ai pris une
poire et à tuyaux qui viennent dans les
papillons de farces et attrapes qui
éclabousse et l'entonnoir parfois de ma
soeur tu penses que tu as fait fortune
avec ça je ne sais pas mais en tout cas
j'ai déjà gagné un voyage à paris
voici une nouveauté présentée en
hollande le gant à éplucher les pommes
de terre
cette paille de fer parmentière permet
d'un simple massage de débarrasser les
tubercules en tout genre de leur
enveloppe chantait désormais se frotter
les mains devient pour la cuisinière âge
est fonctionnel voilà qui ouvre aussi
des perspectives inédites sur la
traditionnelle corvée de pluches ce
ravissant filet jaunâtre auriez vous
deviner qu'il s'agit d'hommes l'aide
concentrer un peu de lait 2 minutes et
nuit depuis son et voilà
vous avez pu faire une omelette sans
casser des oeufs ya une grande assiette
qui soulève à plus d'un mètre au dessus
de la table pour faire plus de 9 sur un
pull un tour violent vos émotions
la mire à quelle époque mon viol